[Music]
and story Update news submitted by
infinity war sad faces
oh I don't watch it I didn't see you
everyone's talking about it I saw I saw
you did a sad I don't know I heard that
people are very disappointed I didn't
watch it but then I heard it was sad and
disappointed and then it was the
greatest and it was the worst I've heard
so many things it just tells you that
everybody in the world saw it's a comic
book movie just enjoy we're done I don't
even going yeah it's the [ __ ] comic
book movie same [ __ ] every time when
people put value into entertainment more
than their real lives
oh sorry for you're talking to a Netflix
culture you're you're the minority here
my friend I know but like that's like
Star Wars guys people are like in like
if it came down to it like oh I gotta
buy this or I cancel my Netflix they're
gonna follow no nobody's canceled on
that I'm not nobody I even have Netflix
I don't even watch anymore cuz I'm on
Jess's account I just like their Netflix
for one show it's just the office the
only thing I just buy the whole thing
then yeah but why cheaper if he doesn't
that's true police have released partial
body cam footage from the Las Vegas
Massacre Oh
whoop-dee-doo so the first police
officer who breached into the room his
body camera wasn't on and that where his
wasn't on no he wasn't on oh yeah for
whatever reason the first guy in his
cameras man
sounds pretty Shady levy did not I did
it for that did he get fired for that
alright so as you guys know there was a
huge massacre that have an October 1st
where 58 people died that's about the
only thing I'm hundreds of people
injured Steven panic was the shooter and
he was found dead in the room by the
time police got there and no motive
there's under today so with
investigation there's not even a clue a
hint without the girlfriend knowing
anything like what the hell is going on
in this world
is it just an act of passion because mad
that was well thought out and he stayed
there for a lot of planning a lot of
guns transported in I saw the footage of
him just rolling it up you saw three
minutes
it's only released they only released
three minutes of footage and he used the
freight elevators in the casino Oh could
I get into a freight elevator in a
casino yeah right the staff helped them
Wow I mean he wanted to stay with the
package yeah yeah they went up there
with the with the staff fishy fishy
so after all this time the police have
finally released partial body cam
footage and this is only because media
outlets sued the police department to
get information because what's happening
here the reason why they've been holding
back is because they're saying that they
wanted to be sensitive to the victims
anyone or make them relive it it also
it's also because it takes a lot of
manpower a lot of money that the city
needs to pay to like review like all of
these cameras that they have all this
footage all the 9-1-1 calls like just
everything that it takes a lot of time
to review all of this [ __ ] that's why
I'm taking up to now that sounds like
[ __ ] sensitive to the victims my
friend because because okay if you want
body cam footage right you just look at
that one footage and then you release
that what are they that's insensitive to
the victims the victims don't want to
know what happens they care about that
but exactly that's what that's the
fallacy of all this they do this to
every single thing that happens they say
we're gonna be sensitive to the victims
themselves were suing to get it exact
they want justice they don't want it
then it's an open wound if you talk
about it again and even though they want
to know it's [ __ ] man so here I'm
gonna show you guys there's a
compilation of the footage that was
released is it edited to really cool
death metal music yeah what's the guy's
[ __ ] head the whole time but it is
very I know yeah it's a joke you saw it
too
active-shooter my airsoft blogs is
better than this mask oh you take one
I'll take the other you got it everybody
okay hey lock the door your door is open
there's there's someone shooting inside
the casino
lock the doors okay cover on that in
with you with you with you second charge
in the stairwell oh wow I like the
Mandalay Bay beautiful rooms yep
really nice rooms what's that yeah so
like the footage that these are released
it's a lot longer but you don't see what
do we learn doesn't really tell us
anything the most interesting thing to
have seen would have been when they went
into the room initially but we were
behind those people because the most
fascinating thing that I saw was a guy
was drinking water and I was like no
he's thirsty yeah hi what is that a
month's energy yeah we did you could
also see that wasn't included in this
the cops were like they find out that
that Stephen put cameras on the cart
yeah the food cart that was outside in
the hallway and there was cameras there
and Mork and they found more cameras so
you see them have that discovery so he
set up pretty much the surveillance
system for himself mm-hmm and so now
they're saying that they're gonna be
providing on a rolling basis the next
batch of footage of 911 cause of like
whatever information that they have that
they'll be rolling it out in the
upcoming weeks so we'll see what else
what's going on that's the whole thing
we don't know nobody knows why why we
know that Steven panic brought 23 guns
into a room right and then he was
helpless with hotel security if you
wanted to get into a service elevator in
Vegas you'd be dragged out of the [ __ ]
impossible but good luck with that but
they let him bring all of his guns up
into the freight elevators like help
them transport all over shoot into his
room he's made this really real wheel
which is not working for a single person
so he's a whale he's a vegas whale
that's the that's the official account
right like he made a bunch of money in
real estate I guess and then he's been
just chillin at casinos four months out
of the year like there's gambling he
booked three rooms and he connected them
all I thought was two but yeah it's it's
the only day you will see a layout okay
he books this suite first at the very
corner yeah and then I think a couple
days later he books the connecting suite
yeah and I think it was about like a
week's time or it's it was several days
that he would come in bring all the guns
whatever do some gambling and then he
would go back come back get some more
guns and he would just stockpile and
then he'd set it up in two different
rooms and then that's the story
basically why why why did he bring all
those guns if he only is gonna use two
that's the weird thing is because why
would you need like 20 something I don't
know how all that all those all that
ammunition - he had a lot of guns and
then he ended up using two or three with
a lump stop all those guys he was gonna
sell that that's what I'm saying so I
think I mean look conspiracies are fun
and entertaining but I also think that
you know they're worth explodes worth
talking about why the [ __ ] no huh we
don't nothing there's just a lot of
things that don't make sense so I I so
the top floor of the Mandalay Bay Hotel
is not owned by the Mandalay Bay it's
owned by a Saudi prince named Prince
Alwaleed bin Talal he they own it they
own the top floor because they owned all
the billionaire yeah they own the Four
Seasons Hotel and so the top floors
considered Four Seasons cuz my dad yeah
I watched his uh lifestyles of the rich
and famous that guy's self-made yeah
like he's a prince
well no he's also definite some
investments like in Facebook and stuff
right like he used a little bit of money
well not little
yeah but he he actually made his wealth
and became a billionaire on his own so
what about the top floor so the top
floor is completely his own by him right
so so this shooting happens like here's
my theory right my running theory is if
you wanted to launder money there's
nowhere better than in Las Vegas Nevada
you could literally walk up to multiple
tables in multiple hotel rooms lay down
cash and you get chips and then you cash
out your chips for clean money like give
me a [ __ ] break
like that's so simple and so that's just
one aspect of it but I also think like
if you're bringing all those guns up to
a rung and you end up only using two
like who's to say that he wasn't running
guns like he wasn't selling guns or
trafficking guns in some way like cuz
why else I mean I mean why else would he
bring all those guns into that room now
maybe he's just some guy who brought a
bunch of guns in the room and he planned
on using every single one of them and
this guy hazers Campos like who was a
security guard ruined his big plan like
by by showing up too early right that's
that's what they say but he had [ __ ]
cameras there like he was ready for
whatever was coming and this guy Campos
he he gets shot I guess in the leg right
and then after this this whole incident
happens he goes to Mexico before he even
gets interviewed by police this the
security got that security guard he goes
to Mexico to visit family or some [ __ ]
that's what the story is then he comes
back and gets interviewed by police it's
the weirdest [ __ ] I've ever heard and he
drove himself down to with a gunshot
wound in his leg right if he if he had
kept the weird thing to me is if he had
a camera right why did he off himself if
you don't care if people are coming or
whatever like it doesn't make any sense
why would you kill yourself because
someone is walking toward you then you
kill some of the security no patek
killed himself right that's what they
say right but then but then that that to
me is like it's so [ __ ] weird it just
doesn't make any sense a month after
this Prince Alwaleed bin Talal same guy
who owns the top floor of the Mandalay
Bay which which was the site of this
terrorist attack gets imprisoned by his
own government along with other members
of the Saudi royal family and they're
all I kept it for four out of four
seasons over there I heard that there
was a power struggle in Saudi Arabia and
there were
sassa nation attempts there were
successful assassinations like there was
a helicopter crash with one of the
princes on board who died like a bunch
of [ __ ] went down so I I don't know if
all this is so tidy is like well he got
Steven paddock wanna do should blow a
bunch of people away that day like I
don't know man I don't I think only
because they have done nothing to help
me understand what happened right so
then people are gonna draw their own
conclusions and tie like all these
things because the media or the
investigation team I don't know like
they're not helping at all these are
slow as hell they have to be sued to
give info it's like Kennedy [ __ ] all
over again look it's the weirdest [ __ ]
yeah and let me tell you something about
white people
anytime you accuse a white guy of
something we will Bend break and [ __ ]
twist all information to try to come up
with a conspiracy clear his good [ __ ]
name
[Music]